hello Internet when's the next Q&A with
gray right now what opinion have you
held for a time and then changed
radically well as mentioned the first
time I talked about changing your mind
this is always hard to discuss because
the specifics are often quite personal
but the biggest non personal thing I've
changed my opinion on is breakfast I
used to believe breakfast was absolutely
vital not just believe it I had evidence
that skipping nay even delaying
breakfast ruined everything
but as I've tried to get healthier
slowly been inconsistently I've
experimented with various things and the
one that shocked me the most is
breakfast is booked but after an
admittedly rough adjustment period my
body no longer needed breakfast and it's
hard to describe just how much of a huge
quality of life improvement this has
been simplifying my normal morning
routine and making early travel days
easier while I'll still eat breakfast
sometimes particularly on vacations
because it's clearly the best of the
three seven meals it's no longer the
necessary part of life I thought it was
what do you want people to remember you
four or five hundred years from now I
don't want to be remembered I want to be
alive but is the most frivolous item you
own man that is a good question that had
me looking up exactly what frivolous
means not having purpose or value so a
thing I own which has neither purpose
nor value I'm not really sure anything I
own fits that description but I'll keep
looking for you if you have an idea in
the shower without phone or notebook
present what do you do hey Siri hey Siri
make a note must not forget million nay
billion dollar idea what do you think of
jazz jazz is the opposite of everything
I like in music I want music to have
patterns and repetition patterns and
repetition this is why I also don't like
live music
I view music as a brain manipulation
tool and to that end jazz is an T useful
to me
do you speak Dutch explain neurons my
mother has neurons MRSA have known a
toll on Smith mine hast broken Tunica
Prada Express in town if you had control
of a superintelligence to which you
could only give one command and it would
execute it to the best approximation of
what you intended what would your one
command be min max happiness and
suffering oh wait
what's one thing that you're not
satisfied with your life right now and
how do you plan to solve it I've gotten
into time tracking pretty deeply I used
to just track my work hours but I began
to record how every hour of every day is
spent and let me tell you no matter how
well you think you spend your time and
no matter how well you do spend your
time tracking all your time is an
unflinching look into a mirror eternally
uncomfortable so I'm not thrilled with
the way my pie chart for the last year
looks it was a year of chaos but it's
not possible to improve without knowing
where you're starting and one of the
ways I'm working to make this better is
simply to have the data about how I
spend my time more visible in more
places I've just begun in the most
baby-steps way possible but so far
making life more visible seems like a
good feedback loop how are you doing
good thanks you if you had to enroll at
a university tomorrow and had to choose
one field of study which would you
choose I'd like to say I take a
programming course but I'm pretty sure I
couldn't pass at the university level
constants and functions and loops oh my
are fun and clear but once it gets to
pointers it's a level too far so if I
needed to pass I probably sign up for
economics I dropped out of that master's
course as mentioned in a previous Q&A
because it wasn't the right fit in my
life at that time but I'd be happy to
give it a go again of all the classes
you've ever taken at uni what was your
hardest what did you hate the most
why well the physics classes in my later
years were the hardest and we're
probably the hardest intellectual thing
I've ever done or will do but that's the
boring er question more interesting
question is which class I hated the most
that was a required humanities reading
class it was one of those classes where
the professor had free rein to just
select a bunch of books they liked and
for students to read them and write
essays agreeing with the professor or
disagreeing in a way the professor
agreed with God did I hate it I really
think it's the kind of class that
professors make mandatory because they
like to teach it and it makes them look
smart and it's easy and not because it's
remotely good for the students involved
anyway it's had to be done and I had a
pretty good idea in advance I would hate
it so at my college there was an option
to compress an entire academic year of
these classes into one intense summer so
I stayed at college over what was
vacation for most people to finish this
class as fast as possible I've always
been pretty good at reading a lot using
an on off schedule when I need to and it
served me well here I think I read
something like 30 stupid or boring or
flowery or pompous books over that
summer anyway it works so well it was a
strategy I used every summer compressing
as many dumb mandatory classes into as
short a time as possible if your school
gives that as an option I highly
recommend it so you have more time
during the rest of the year to focus on
more important things raisins and
chocolate chip cookies gross what noise
do you wake up to none
I used to use music to wake up to
because this is the world's most
unpleasant sound but doing so trains
yourself to dislike whatever song you
use and have it randomly caused you a
sense of drowning anxiety when you hear
it in a different context I used to use
a seagull Ross song during my teaching
years to wake me up and I still can't
hear the opening few seconds without
feeling like I'm drowning
a decade later of course the sound may
be none but I currently use my Apple
watch to wake me up with a vibration and
I know I'm in a good routine when I wake
up naturally before it goes off if you
could have one superpower excluding the
power to have all powers what would it
be invulnerability with an exit option
can you wear silly ties for the rest of
the video
no I spent years plotting and scheming
how to escape the world of ties I will
not go back to it now you are given the
opportunity to permanently and
irreversibly change one fundamental law
of physics what would it be and why on
the panel of fundamental laws and
constants I've draped a very big do not
touch sign how do I get over a crippling
factorio addiction you tell me man I'm
over a thousand hours deep do you feel
that humans need not apply needs
updating has anything changed since its
creation that would change your message
not really anything I would change
I do enjoy that the debate around autos
has switched from they'll never happen -
why aren't they here now which is an
interesting question at least in this
moment it feels like progress and
self-driving cars is a bit of an s-curve
so maybe I was over optimistic about the
rapid approach of commercially-available
autos but I still think they're coming
and
if I can't buy or rent an auto within
ten years of the publication of that
video I'll be surprised and disappointed
what is love what is love baby don't
hurt me don't hurt me no more lastly of
course Lee who is sponsoring this
episode it's a new sponsor to the
channel Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community with over
20,000 classes in design business
technology and more the great thing
about the Internet is you can learn real
useful skills without having to take
those mandatory college classes and
Skillshare is a great place to do that
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on just
about everything allowing you to acquire
new skills and unlock new opportunities
in your life I'm certainly going to
recommend that if you are watching this
video you might want to check out
they're learning how to program classes
if you want to get started in mobile
development or any kind of development
skills share has lots of high quality
classes for you go to sk l dot s h slash
CGP grey the first 500 to use the link
in the description will get their first
two months of skill share for free again
that's sk l dot s h slash CGP grey or
click the link in the description do
your future self a favor and start
learning those new skills today